[MUSIC PLAYING]
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: So
welcome, everyone.
Welcome to GCP NEXT 2016.
I'm Prajakta, product manager
in the Cloud Networking
team at Google in the
Google Cloud Platform.
So let's start with you today.
You just sold your CIO on the
idea of moving your workloads
to the Google Cloud.
Congratulations.
Yeah, you started first
with saying, yeah,
we have on-demand
access to compute.
You're going to
save tons of money.
But what really clinched
the deal for you was this--
Google Cloud Platform's
world-class infrastructure
and Google Cloud Platform's
best-of-the-breed services.
That is why Google Cloud
Platform gives you the ability
to deliver your
services anywhere
anytime across the globe.
So how does Google Cloud
Platform deliver your services
reliably across the globe
with high performance
and with low latency?
A key cloud service that lets
it do this is Google Global Load
Balancing.
And that is the focus
of my talk today.
I'm sure all of you are
familiar with load balancers,
but maybe let's do
a Load Balancer 101.
Now, load balance
is what created
to deliver high availability
and to scale the services.
And if you look at a load
balancer, as you can see there,
you have your back ends.
These are the ones that
actually service your clients.
You stick a load
balancer in front,
you put a front-end VIP
on it, and voila, you
have a service where
the load is distributed
across all of these servers.
You have a service
that's resilient,
because if one of these
fails, your load balancer will
seamlessly route the request
to another healthy instance.
You can scale your service
now, because you simply
stick another server
there and it scales up.
And lastly, a load
balancer is the one
that hosts your front-end VIP.
So one more thing that I talked
about in the previous one--
it's Load Balancing 101.
Now let's look at
it from the point
of view of a cloud provider.
Look at the cloud.
You have a multi-tenant
environment.
You have thousands of users.
You have compute resources that
are scattered across the world.
And then you need the
ability to seamlessly scale
as the number of your users
and the traffic grows.
So you look here.
You see three or four
flavors of load balancing.
The first one is your
hardware load balancers.
Think of them.
I'm sure all of
you have used them.
They have fixed form factor.
So if you need more
throughput, what do you do?
You go and buy a bigger box.
If you need more
features, what do you do?
You approach the vendor,
and you wait for the release
to put the features in.
HA is pretty much active-active
or active-standby.
And these are definitely
expensive to load-balance
at scale, especially
cloud scale.
Next come the software
load balancers.
And when I talk of
software load balancers,
I mean load balancing logic
that runs in a VM instance.
Could be a cluster.
Right?
Now, these are
definitely a step up,
but is that enough to deliver
cloud-scale load balancing?
That is where the Google
Cloud Platform Global Load
Balancing comes in.
It's basically a
software-defined, globally
distributed load balancing.
That is exactly what Google
Global Load Balancing is.
And today I wanted to
shed some light on it.
So there are some
interesting aspects about it
that I wanted to highlight.
So first, let's
start with you again.
Why do you want global
application delivery?
Maybe you want to deliver your
services around the globe.
Maybe you need the highest
levels of availability,
so you want to replicate your
services around the globe
or you want to deliver your
services with low latency
close to wherever
your users are.
That is what Google Global Load
Balancing enables you to do.
Instantiate your workloads
anywhere you want in the globe.
But unlike traditional,
DNS-based load balancing
solutions, you don't have
to front-end each region
with its own IP.
You can front-end
them with a single IP.
Finally, you can deliver low
latency and high bandwidth
connectivity for all your users.
And with all of this, you can
think of Google Global Load
Balancing as having
infinite capacity.
So as your users and
your traffic increase,
it just seamlessly scales.
Now let's take maybe a
sneak peek at what's inside.
Because often, I get asked,
where is the Google Global Load
Balancer?
The answer is it's everywhere.
It's not a single box,
it's not running in a VM,
it's not a cluster.
It's load balancing
distributed across the world.
And there are four
key technologies
that make this happen--
one, software-defined load
balancing; two,
Google's global network;
three, seamless autoscaling; and
fourth is intelligent anycast.
So how many of
you have not heard
of software-defined networking?
Raise your hand.
OK.
That's great.
So basically, this is
software-defined load
balancing, which
builds on the concepts
of software-defined networking.
Now let's look at the right.
As you can see there, that is
what the Google Global Load
Balancer does.
If you look at the
traditional load balancer,
you see a single load balancer.
If you look on the right, which
is the Google side of things,
there is no load balancer.
And the reason for
that is load balancing
is done by distributed,
software-defined entities
called Google front ends.
We call them GFEs very lovingly.
And the GFEs themselves are
distributed across the world.
And they work in
conjunction with a number
of other
software-defined systems
to do global load balancing.
Now, what they really enable
you to do-- as you can see,
they are at the edge
of the Google network.
And you can see
a number of GFEs.
So when somebody says,
where is the load balancing,
it's in each of
these GFEs, which
are scattered around the word.
The GFEs enable you to terminate
your user traffic closest
to your user.
And they load-balance
the user request
to the closest healthy back
end with available capacity.
So they do work with other
software-defined systems
to do very sophisticated
load balancing, which
is a function of
proximity and capacity--
so available
capacity, essentially.
Now let's look at the
second key enabler.
That's Google's global network.
Google has 70+ edge POPs
across 33 countries.
And it has a high-quality
private network
for edge-to-data
center connectivity.
So each of these are
connected to the data center,
and you are computing the data
centers through this very, very
high-quality network.
Now, out of these 70 edge
POPs, these load-balancing GFEs
are placed in 50 of these
POPs close to your users
across the globe.
So again, as I said before,
if anybody asks you,
where is the GCP
Global Load Balancer,
the answer is it's at
all of these 50-plus POPs
across the globe.
Now let's look at these two
diagrams a little bit closely.
Because your next
question should be,
sure, you let me put this
close to the user, what's
the benefit for me?
Look at the left.
That's your traditional
cloud provider.
Your user's request
is going to traverse
just the general internet
for a majority of time
and finally reach the load
balancer in your cloud
provider's data center.
Now let's look at the Google
Global Cloud Load Balancing.
If you notice, the
GFEs are sitting
very close to your user.
So the first line, which
is your TCP session one,
your user request is barely
traversing the internet, right?
And this means
because it traverses
the internet for a
short time, beyond that,
the GFEs will make
sure that they
deliver your request
over Google's
high-quality private network.
And what does this do for you?
The benefits are significant--
reduced latency and improved
throughput for your users.
Delivering unflappable
services even in the wake
of stability or instability.
And one thing which
is not obvious
but which I wanted
to point out--
serving static, cachable
contents from multiple points
near your users.
So why doesn't
everybody do this?
This way of load balancing
is not easy to architect.
It needs a global network, and
it needs sophisticated software
and distributed technologies.
And Google has been doing
this for the last 15 years.
And that's what we are really
leveraging for Google Cloud
Load Balancing.
So let's come to the third part.
A question we often
get asked-- how many
VMs should I provision
for my service?
For that, the first
thing you should do
is look at your workload.
Maybe your business
is growing fast,
so you need to
scale up steadily.
Or maybe you have
bursty traffic.
Or maybe your traffic
is on and off in nature.
Maybe you're running
batch workloads.
Then you come to the classic
resource allocation problem.
If you provision for peak,
you're wasting resources.
If you provision for average,
you are in big trouble.
So the ideal way is to provision
in line with your traffic.
And this is where Google Cloud
Platform Autoscaling comes in.
It intelligently adjusts
resources based on load.
So if your traffic grows,
so do your resources.
If your traffic shrinks, your
resources shrink as well.
But most importantly,
to do this well,
this autoscaling
does the scale-up
in a matter of seconds.
There is no pre-warming needed.
So if there was one
takeaway about autoscaling,
I want you to take
that away with you.
Now, how do you
provision autoscaling?
So basically, you provision
autoscale instance groups
and you specify an
autoscaling policy.
It's a very intuitive,
intent-based policy.
You say stuff like, OK, keep
my VMs at 85% utilization.
Now, Autoscaler, it'll
monitor your instances,
it'll work closely with
the Global Load Balancer,
and it makes sure that if
the capacity of your VMs
goes below the
configured threshold,
it'll scale them up in
a matter of seconds.
The last key technology
I wanted to talk about
is Intelligent Anycast.
Now, let's look
at this technology
through the lens of
an actual deployment.
Let's say you decided
to host www.myapp.com
in the Google Cloud.
Your users are all
over the world,
so you put your compute
instances in three regions.
Let's say you put them in US
central Google data centers
in Europe and then in Asia.
Now, normally with any
other cloud provider,
you would have had three
DNS VIPs, one per region.
And then you would have
to use DNS load balancing
to sort of send them
to the correct region.
If you have used
DNS-based load balancers--
so like global server
load balancers--
I can say that
confidently, because I
don't code for a lot of them.
You have a bunch of issues
that you have to deal with.
First of all, DNS-based
load balancers
take minutes if not hours to
detect and react to change.
They also suffer
from resolver caching
and other well-known
detail-based issues.
Now, if you look
at it in contrast,
let's look at the
Intelligent Anycast.
You have a single IP, so there
is no problem with caching.
Wherever you go,
it's the same IP.
What that means is Maya in
California, Bob in London,
and then Shen in Singapore,
they each use 120.1.1.1
to reach your
service, myapp.com.
Intelligent Anycast
also directs them
to the resource
that's closest to them
with available capacity.
And there are a lot of things
that I have not put here.
But for instance, if
they are routing flaps,
it'll ensure that
your request goes
to the correct place, the place
that can serve it reliability
and can serve it well.
So your next question will
be, yes, this sounds great,
how do I get started?
Just go to the Google
Cloud Platform website
and get started configuring it.
Select the flavor of your load
balancers-- whether you want
HTTP as load balancing
in this case.
Select and deploy
your back ends.
Consider a front-end Anycast
VIP, and you're done.
I don't know if you
can see things clearly,
but what I wanted to
show is a new UI that's
making its debut next month.
It's as simple as just picking
the first option, start
configuring.
And then you go considering the
three steps that we put there.
I purposely didn't
show you the other two,
because I want to highly
encourage you to go and try
them out yourself.
So honestly, the biggest
benefit or the biggest advantage
that Google Cloud Load Balancing
delivers is peace of mind.
You can see the quote
on the screen, right?
That is one happy
customer on the screen.
And there are many more
who would say the same.
So I highly encourage
you to try it,
and I'm sure it will give you
the same peace of mind as well.
One last interesting thing
I wanted to point out
is that Google Global Load
Balancing not only delivers
your cloud services,
but it's just
as essential to
Google's own services.
It uses the same set of
software-defined technologies
and the same global
infrastructure
that are being used to
deliver Google Search, Gmail,
and other Google services.
So definitely use
this information
when you're trying to clinch
getting your CIO to move
the workloads to the cloud.
So with that, it's
time to see Global Load
Balancing in action.
Please welcome our next speaker,
Anna, tech lead for Global Load
Balancing, to show you how to
deliver reliable services not
just at cloud scale,
but at not full scale.
Thank you.
Hey, Anna.
[APPLAUSE]
ANNA BERENBERG:
Thank you, Prajakta.
Today we will be looking beyond
cloud scale availability.
All cloud providers
publish their SLA.
Some publish 3 nines, some
publish 3 and 1/2 nines
like GCP.
But what if you want to
build an application that
has 5 nine availabilities
or even beyond that?
That's how Google
built its applications.
There is a short
answer for that.
Use Global Load Balancing.
With Global Load Balancing, you
get worldwide capacity anytime
anything happens.
You get the protection
against region-wide failures.
And with cross-regional overflow
and cross-regional failover,
you're getting highly
available solution.
Today they're
going to be working
through the example of highly
available Globally Load
Balanced service, Santa Tracker.
Who doesn't like Santa, whether
you're a child, an adult, or in
between.
It's always fun to watch
Santa to deliver presents.
And while Santa is busy
delivering presents
around the world, you
and I, as service owners,
will pay attention to
traffic volume and shape,
and get to experience a series
of disasters that typically
happen over service lifetime.
We'll start with configuring
Santa Tracker Service on GCP
with configuring it
in three continents.
Why?
Because service is
global, and Santa's
going to be traveling
around the world.
We will create one instance
group in Asia, one in Europe,
and two in United
States to account
for anticipated traffic.
Unfortunately, I was up all
night prepping for our talk.
And after playing with the
manual added instances,
I forgot to enable
Autoscaler in Asia.
So watch for it.
It's going to bite us later on.
As the days start, Santa is hard
at work delivering presents.
And while children and
adult watching him to drop
presents through the chimneys,
you and I looking at a console.
And guess what?
The traffic volume is a little
higher than anticipated.
In fact, it is a lot higher.
So on one hand, we are happy
that our service is so popular.
On another hand, we don't
know what's going to happen.
Do we have enough
capacity to serve?
Are we prepared for success?
And indeed, interest in
Santa is not letting up.
And now we have a lot
of traffic incoming.
And suddenly, we see
overflow to Europe.
What just happened?
Well, what happened-- we go back
and look at our configuration
and we figure out that we
didn't have Autoscaler enabled.
So our Global Load
Balancer saved us
from the outage and
overflow excess of traffic
to closest region.
But then without
any intervention.
So we go back,
enable Autoscaler.
And as Autoscaler is starting
instances, health check,
and they are ready
to serve, the traffic
is moving back to China,
to Asia, serving locally
with a minimal latency.
As day goes by, now
Santa is in Europe.
Our instances in Europe just
got new binary with support
for elvish language.
Unfortunately, the feature
wasn't tested well.
So the first time elves,
the Santa helpers,
tried to check the
status of Santa
Tracker, the binary crash.
Don't panic.
Nothing happens.
Our Global Load
Balancer immediately
recognized the health
of failed instances
and moved traffic away.
Let's stop here for a second
and analyze what just happened.
There are no other
cloud provider that
has cross-regional failovers.
And let's see whether
regional failover would work.
And it wouldn't, because all
binaries within the region
are running the same version.
So as long as elves continue
to send query of death,
the binary would
continue to crash.
Our Global Load Balancer,
on the other hand,
practically picks number
of failover candidates
without any configuration.
All of it's done automatically.
And based on the health,
size, and remaining capacity,
it constantly recomputes new
failovers every two seconds.
And you look at it, and
you see that lines are
going a little bit far away.
But what we say-- that even
though the traffic is moving
in US and temporarily
you're getting
a little bit higher
latency, it's
much better that not
being able to serve in US.
Right?
Because that's what would
happen should we stay in Europe.
So we're all backed
default binary.
And now previously stable
binary runs without elvish.
So poor elves would have
to query in English.
Next year then.
This is a second time when
Global Load Balancing saved us
from full region outage.
As the day goes by, Santa is
traveling and delivers present
now in America.
With a single Load
Balance [INAUDIBLE],
our users experience
best latency as users
from each coast come to the
close as instance groups.
And as day comes to the close
and we think we're almost done,
Rudolph the Reindeer went
on a famous talk show,
and endorsed the Santa,
and then also said
that why don't you go and check
out our favorite Santa Tracker?
And sure enough, million of
peoples flock to our website,
creating a perfect storm of
locally generated traffic.
We are holding our breath.
What is going to happen?
Because there is
so much traffic,
that even buffers
that Autoscaler
kept for extra capacity are
being overrun immediately.
But our load balancer
saves us again.
Within seconds,
starting to move traffic
where additional capacity is.
Starting from the closest
and then going further away,
if there is not
enough capacity still.
In the meantime, our
Autoscaler grew back up.
And the traffic caused by
Rudolph is moved back to US
and is now served locally.
And as viewer attention
moved on, so did the traffic.
And now we are back to
our regular service.
Global [INAUDIBLE] saved
us yet again-- this time,
from multi-region outage.
After delivering
presents in Hawaii,
Santa is getting
well-deserved rest.
And we can look back at our
long day and see what happened.
Global Load Balancing helped
us to successfully serve
huge number of [INAUDIBLE]
and averted three
potential disasters.
In Asia, we had an
error in configuration,
which was mitigated by
cross-region overflow
and then pulling back when
Autoscaler grew back up.
We survived the crash of
our European instances
and mitigated it by
temporarily rerouting traffic
to United States.
And in United
States, we rode out
perfect storm of locally
generated traffic
by moving traffic and dipping
in worldwide in the capacity.
Obviously, I didn't
talk about all cases
that could have happened.
And so I encourage you to
pick your favorite case
and analyze it in the presence
of Global Load Balancer.
I hope this example of running
globally load-balanced, highly
available service persuaded you
that global load balancing is
the way to build scalable,
reliable, and highly available
global load balancing.
Come and try it.
HTTPS, it will be on GCP.
And to further learn about
best-in-class Global Load
Balancer, please welcome Matt
Smart, tech lead and manager
at Google.
[APPLAUSE]
MATT SMART: Thanks, Anna.
So as Anna demonstrated,
global load balancing
is an important tool to improve
reliability, and availability,
and serve your users
with low latency.
To even further reduce
latency for your users,
you can use a Content
Delivery Network, or CDN.
A CDN will cache your site's
content all around the world,
speeding delivery to your users
while also offloading work
from your back ends.
To that end, the
Google Cloud Platform
has partnered with
six CDN operators
through our CDN
Interconnect Program.
With CDN Interconnect, you'll
get optimized connections
to your CDN of choice and
pay less for network egress.
And in the coming weeks, we'll
be launching the beta release
of Google Cloud CDN.
Google Cloud CDN is our
own delivery network,
and it integrates seamlessly
with the Global Load Balancer.
We've deployed our global
load balancing stack
at more than 50 points of
presence around the globe,
as Prajakta mentioned earlier.
And it integrates
with Google Cloud CDN
at each of those locations.
With Google Cloud CDN,
your cacheable content
can be served
directly to your users
from each of those 50 locations.
Not only do you get
a world-class edge
presence backed by the global
network Prajakta mentioned.
Your cacheable content can
be served directly to your--
you can partition your site
based on the back-end service
to enable CDN for
only those portions
of your back-end services
that's highly cacheable.
Leave off your admin
APIs, but use it
for your static content,
your CSS, your JavaScript,
maybe those elvish and
English language files,
all without hosting
it on a new domain.
You can also analyze
how well you're
doing with a cloud
monitoring, which
is stacked right for
integration and cloud logging.
So as we saw with
Santa, you know
you're going to have
a lot of traffic,
but you might not know how much.
Why should you need
to send test traffic
or trickles of live traffic just
to warm up your load balancers?
When we created the network
load balancer, which
is a precursor to the global
load balancing for TCP and UDP
traffic, we wanted to
take it for a spin,
so we did what any
normal Googler would do.
We threw a million
queries per second at it.
So Global Load Balancing, we
wanted to do the same thing.
In this case, we took
it up to 1.3 million.
And then we stopped, because
well, just we wanted to stop.
And as you could see, this
is to a single anycast
address, no DNS load balancing
required, between regions.
And all this traffic is
being sunk at whatever region
slow traffic is coming from.
In this case, we both had
the sink and the source
in these three locations listed.
Again, no pre-warming necessary.
Up, over, down.
With Google Cloud CDN and
Global Load Balancing,
we decreased latency
in a couple of ways.
The first, again, is by
having these locations
all around the world
physically close to your users.
A second is by supporting
modern protocols,
like HTTP2, which reuse the
network very well and more
efficiently.
So let's look at how well we do.
This first section--
we've got your application
deployed in a single region.
In this case, US East 1.
And the data is showing
median load time
for 100-kilobyte files.
We're doing pretty
well in New York.
That's that little red bar.
But the rest of the
world is pretty grumpy.
And we like the
rest of the world.
The second part-- we've
deployed our application
in more regions.
In this case, both US
regions, Asia, and Europe.
It's gotten much better,
but the gold and the green,
South America and
Australia, they're
still not quite that happy.
And we want to do better.
The third part-- we've
enabled Cloud CDN.
I can't see what
that says anymore.
I think they're
pretty happy now.
So our users depend on
Google Cloud Platform
to deliver resilient
autoscaled services
with a global footprint.
We've described how
Global Load Balancing fits
into that picture,
but you really
don't have to take
my word for it.
Let's hear from a power user
of Google Cloud Load Balancing.
Please welcome Dmitry from Wix.
[APPLAUSE]
DMITRY SHESTAK: Thank you, Matt.
Hi.
I am Dmitry.
I am solution
architect at wix.com.
I want to tell you how you too
can move our services to Google
Cloud.
Sorry, it's going
to be this one.
So what is Wix?
For those of you who are not
familiar with the company,
it's easy,
what-you-see-is-what-you-get
service to building a website.
So business owners,
even nontechnical ones,
can easily build the site
for the company the way
they want to see it.
And the platform is built up of
many services, many products,
and hundreds of services.
But today I only want
to talk about one
of them, which is image
serving and manipulation.
So the service itself is
very simple and basic.
It's exactly what
it sounds like.
Site owner uploads an image.
Site visitors come and
sees it on the website.
But we do not serve
original images.
We resize them,
adjusts them on the fly
to improve user experience.
So if you, like,
open the same website
on a desktop and
mobile device, you
will get the same images
in different dimensions.
And the numbers you are seeing
here growing month after month.
Just like today's snapshot.
So we have mixed storage to
handle many requests to serve.
And today, I have to say,
we run on active-active set
upon both Google and Amazon.
And I can tell you a lot
about platform differences.
Subject to totally
different talk.
So let's start with
some history first.
Four years ago, we were running
on free, on-prem data centers.
This means storing
each image three times.
And the machines that were
doing the image manipulation
were keeping the images
in the local storage.
The downsides are quite obvious.
With the growth we have, we
had to double our capacity each
four or five months without
stopping the service,
moving the files.
Not a nice task to do.
Don't do it.
Please, don't.
And of course,
there's the hardware.
You have to keep your
maintenance going.
You have controllers failing.
You have [INAUDIBLE] failing.
You have batteries.
Just name it.
Everything can go wrong.
So we start moving to the cloud.
And at the very beginning,
it was not easy.
Many features go missing.
So we had to be very creative.
So what we were doing
at the very beginning.
We were serving the traffic
with network load balancer
through one single
region, and we
were manually creating
our own instances,
adjusting the size of our setup.
It means if we were expecting
more traffic to hit,
you were creating just enough
instances to handle it.
Now, Wix strongly believes
in continuous integration
and continuous delivery.
With the hundreds
of services we have,
have a new version hitting G8
every couple of minutes, OK?
No one can predict
which one of them
might affect images traffic.
No one.
We had to be very responsive.
Not recommended.
Long nights.
So when Autoscaler arrived, it
just changed the way we live,
changed the way we do anything.
It removed this need to
configure and attune things
manually.
We could sleep at night finally.
Autoscaler, it's a very
critical part of the system.
It was mentioned before,
but put little think in it.
If you have too many
instances running,
you just pay with extra money.
Well, if you have not
enough instances running,
you have to pay with
your system latency.
You pay with your
system availability.
You pay with your customers, OK?
And Google Autoscaler keeps
you with just right amount
of instances even
at traffic peaks.
And it adapts extremely fast.
It took us time to put
trust in Autoscalar.
Today we know we can trust
it, but it took us time.
I will give you just
one example that we had.
There were an autoscaled
instance group
running with a metrics below
the threshold for a long time
without any missed
instance being removed.
Strange behavior.
So we opened a support case.
We had a conversation
with the team.
What we realized is that
Autoscaler took care of us.
Removing even one
single instance
would raise the traffic,
hitting the remaining instances.
That would raise the
metric above the threshold.
New instances would be created.
So Autoscaler was smart enough
to keep us from this flopping.
It just kept us safe.
Of course, also,
the health checks.
When Global HTTP Load
Balancer came out,
it finally allowed us
to serve the traffic
from multiple regions.
We could stay up whatever
happens in any single region.
It was fantastic.
Now we can control the traffic
to hit specific instance
groups.
And the opposite-- we can drain
the traffic from the others.
Of course, there are additional
pieces in the puzzle.
You have deployment manager.
You have preemptible VMs.
And by the way,
preemptible VMs are
one of the reasons we
prefer the traffic to hit
specific instance groups.
It's fantastic.
It's all easily configurable,
and it goes from zero
to full scale in
matter of seconds.
I will give you just this
small example of traffic.
Small weekly traffic we have.
You can see the traffic goes
up and down as the day goes by.
And you can see the amount of
instances adjust accordingly.
Magically.
No hands involved.
Everything's goes automatically.
And you can see
the response time
stays the way it should be.
It stays the way we defined it.
And the most exciting
things that I like,
look at the bottom-right graph.
You see this traffic?
Spread across 14
different instance
groups in different zones
of different regions.
And you can easily see.
When traffic of
some instance group
falls down for any particular
reason-- like preemptible VMs
were taken from us or we
deployed faulty version--
it hands over automatically
to other instance groups,
and no harms to service happens.
We stay up 100%.
So if you haven't tried all
this magic before, just do it.
So let me hand you to Prajakta
to summarize those things.
[APPLAUSE]
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: Thank you.
DMITRY SHESTAK: Mm.
MALE SPEAKER: Good job.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: So hi, folks.
I'm back.
And the reason I'm
back is, first of all,
to thank Dmitry and Wix
for being here with us.
And whatever we say
at the end of the day,
if customers say that,
it's probably much,
much more powerful.
So that's why I wanted you
to hear from him personally.
So thank you, Dmitry.
The reason I'm here is because
if you leave this room--
and I'm hoping you
do after we are done.
But when you leave
this room, you
leave with four key takeaways.
First, our Global Load Balancing
is software-defined load
balancing for cloud scale.
It uses state-of-the-art
software-defined technologies
and distributive systems
technologies along with,
of course, Google's
global network.
The second one is you
can deliver your services
across the globe with a
single anycast front-end VIP.
You will not find this in
any other cloud provider.
Third, it will deliver
high performance,
low latency, and seamless
scaling, or rather,
seamless autoscaling
for all your services.
And lastly, you can
optimize your delivery
across the globe using three
things-- Cloud CDN, CDN
Interconnect, and of course
Google's global network that
enables all of this.
So with that, I think we
come to the end of it.
Feel free to get
any one of us if you
have any further question.
And with that, let's
conclude and say, scale on!
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]